The change from cytosine to thymine is considered a
nonsense mutation, because it changes an arginine codon to
a stop codon. Now, this ends protein synthesis prematurely,
and you get a very shortened and highly dysfunctional
protein. And without a fully functioning protein, an individual
is likely to be effected by a kind of
red green color blindness called protanopia. Which means that
instead of seeing a normal color spectrum like this,
they're actually less sensitive to red light. And the
color spectrum looks like this instead. As you can see,
there's very little difference between what should appear green and
what should appear red. Thus the name, red-green color blindness.